we have Ryan Matthey Ryanair Sahara and
Valley View where Las Vegas fire
responded to a situation over at herbs
and rye and Ryan what is that update
Brian Christian it's a popular
restaurant potentially nobody was inside
but confirmed one man was on the roof
I'll step off to the side you can see
the cleanup efforts here from Clark
County Fire and Las Vegas fire the
battalion chief Kenny Holdings they say
they dispatched a first alarm that's
about 12 units 40 Personnel initial
reports were that somebody was on the
roof and it was on fire a curious case
as the restaurant says on their social
medias they're closed at least
throughout the holiday weekend no
injuries reported so far no one was
transported to the hospitals the
battalion chief says now on the other
side we do see a broken window some
burnt trash out here but nothing too
graphic as of yet you can see these
people are currently cleaning up this
was reported just around 3 20 a few or
actually within the past hour or so
coming back live to me here they're
currently unclear how this fire started
that's the Curiosity of this all we've
reached out to the restaurant owner to
see if he can provide a little bit more
info we get to hear back but if you stay
updated on our website 8 news now for
the most recent updates we'll be
updating that as well for now sending it
back to you guys in the studio reporting
live out here from Urban Ryan with
Sahara Ryan Matthey 8 News Now